[Musique]
avec son cinéma vérité elle ne laisse
personne indifférent cette attrait s'est
réalisatrice ultra précoce inspirée et
toute une nouvelle génération de
cinéastes et chacun de ces films fait
l'événement pour de bonnes ou de
mauvaises raisons d'ailleurs cette
nouvelle cas avec Jeanne du Barry qui se
rapprochait demain en ouverture du
Festival de Cannes d'apparence son film
le moins personnel vous allez plus à un
paradoxe près et elle va sans doute nous
prouver le contraire dans un instant
Maïwenn est un aparté
bonjour bienvenue en aparté
ravi de vous accueillir
vous allez bien
c'est troublant
c'est marrant j'avais pas cette image là
la télé OK et puis il y a le regard de
la cinéaste que vous êtes aussi
oui
je m'excuse je
regarde vous regardez si on a tout bon
ou pas
est-ce qu'on est bien sur vos
fondamentaux oui c'est déjà un bon point
comment vous vous sentez là dans cet
espace ça va vous avez vu la cour
d'honneur du château de Versailles bien
sûr dans la baie vitrée on y est presque
j'étais persuadé que vous allez me
mettre vous alliez me mettre le port
d'Alger
des doigts
on est pas loin
sans les heures de vol comme ça
téléportation
c'est le lieu qui vous appelle par
dessus tout oui vous êtes
particulièrement chez vous oui je me
sens chez moi mais quand même étrangère
c'est à dire que j'y suis allée tout au
long de ma vie mais j'aime la sensation
de me sentir chez moi c'est comme dans
les bras de mon homme je me sens
d'ailleurs je lui dis souvent quand je
suis dans tes bras je suis en Algérie
et puis il y a des endroits à Paris où
je me sens pas chez moi mais je me sens
pas non plus étrangère je me sens en
français mais pas chez moi à Alger en
Algérie d'ailleurs tout court je me sens
chez moi parce que
le trait de caractère des Algériens leur
humour leur intégrité leur dignité
c'est mon enfance c'est ma famille c'est
puis c'est le bon côté de ma famille
aussi surtout c'est vos grands-parents
c'est mes grands-parents oui
essentiellement mon grand votre
grand-père votre relation je crois était
très fort très fusionnel ça se passe
dans l'échange qu'est-ce qui vous a
transmis c'est surtout mes
grands-parents parce que c'était
vraiment un couple fusionnel mon âge
est-ce que vous voulez vous asseoir
d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi non c'est pour
vous si vous voulez être plus
confortable alors plusieurs propositions
le canapé le fauteuil marron le bar ce
qui vous semble le plus tentant allez
canapé oui c'est grand-parents ses
grands-parents ils sont ils sont
évidemment une un socle fondamental oui
vos fondations oui absolument c'était
des gens
très simples qui avait
aussi beaucoup de culture et tout mais
qui avaient l'intelligence du coeur et
qui avait une vie simple ils habitaient
au premier étage d'un immeuble où mes
parents vivaient au quatrième puis après
quand mes parents se sont séparés mon
père a continué à vivre au quatrième
étage donc quand j'allais voir mon père
je passais toujours par le premier étage
pour voir mes grands-parents
et ce que j'aimais c'était
réconfortant et faisait chaud
c'était propre
tu vois il y avait tout le temps à
manger c'était il y avait tout le temps
la télé c'était réconfortant c'était
apaisant
et j'aimais bien le côté rituel chez eux
on mangeait à 20h pile devant le journal
télévisé de TF1 on regardait Anne
Sinclair j'adorais les habitudes avec
eux ma mère ma grand-mère cousait au
coin du feu
et
[Musique]
parce que chez moi c'était le chaos en
fait chez ma mère et chez mon père
c'était le chaos donc j'avais besoin de
d'être assuré avec eux vous avez un
prénom Breton Maïwenn oui vous auriez pu
vous choisir ou un prénom algérien aussi
je m'appelle Nedjma
vous préférez oui
je crois que ma mère voulait m'appeler
Nedjma mais c'est mon père qui a eu le
dernier mot
alors évidemment Alger c'est les
souvenirs c'est des madeleines de Proust
c'est des goûts des odeurs mais
Versailles j'ai fait un détour parce que
j'ai vu le film j'ai adoré Jeanne dubary
Jeanne dubarif finalement c'est une
rencontre elle est vous c'est une
rencontre entre les moins absolument oui
je me suis j'ai eu un coup de foudre une
obsession sur cette femme sur sa vie
et aussi sur l'époque finalement parce
que
j'ai pas que lu sur elle
et je pensais que le désir allait partir
au fur et à mesure parce que j'ai quand
même découvert cette femme en 2006 dans
le film de Sophia Coppola qui était joué
par hasard Gento et bon généralement moi
quand je me lance dans un film j'ai dû
désir pendant 6 mois un an après j'ai
tendance à me lasser ou à passer à autre
chose et c'est ce qui s'est passé quand
j'ai eu envie de faire ADN j'ai cru que
Jeanne Dubarry était morte
et bizarrement le désir est revenu je ne
sais pas comment Jeanne dubary qui va
être là ça y est c'est imminent projeté
à Cannes bien sûr vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit fébrile enthousiaste oui
je suis fébrile je suis un mélange de
tout ça c'est un peu l'ascenseur
émotionnel
tantôt je suis excitée tantôt je suis
angoissée parce que la sortie étant le
même jour c'est important de le préciser
j'ai jamais vécu ça
et puis j'ai fini le film il y a très
peu de temps en fait il y a une dizaine
de jours donc je suis j'aimerais
tellement encore être derrière ma table
de montage j'ai changé des choses puis
c'est trop tard ça y est parce qu'on
veut toujours changer des choses moi oui
en tout cas
on va regarder quand même quelques
images si vous êtes d'accord un extrait
de la bande-annonce on regarde on s'en
parle après
la comtesse jade du Barry
surtout
ne regardez pas le roi dans les yeux ce
serait perçu par la cour comme une
invitation
à quoi à la baguette
[Musique]
père nous sommes devenus la reset de
Versailles à cause de vos égarements le
Premier ministre ne va pas tolérer que
vous laissiez une fille des rues côtoyer
votre entourage c'est une femme et mon
entourage
[Musique]
je vous aime
beaucoup de fou pour que cette misérable
femme soit chassée de la cour
loin d'autres maîtresse est en train de
découvrir
le côté sombre du roi
[Musique]
Maïwenn ce film Jeanne du Bary qui
arrive sur le tapis rouge évidemment sur
la Croisette avec vous bien sûr ce
casting 5 étoiles avec cette histoire
qui nous embarque Benjamin Lavergne
extraordinaire Pierre Richard tout aussi
épatant Melville Poupaud et Johnny Depp
bien sûr un casting 5 étoiles oui et
puis et puis une histoire une histoire
très forte vous l'avez dit vous aviez
été embarqué depuis 2006 mais qu'est-ce
qui vous a tellement séduit chez ce
personnage
d'abord avant de vous répondre je crois
qu'il y a des choses que je maîtrise pas
et que je ne cherche pas à maîtriser
j'ai vite
d'analyser pourquoi j'aime les gens et
les choses et les films
mais je crois je crois que la vie de
Jeanne du Barry pourrait ressembler à
une espèce de métaphore sur ma vie c'est
à dire
Versailles pourrait ressembler pour être
le milieu du cinéma hostile qu'on
descendant que j'ai rencontré quand j'ai
commencé à vouloir faire des films
et puis ce que j'aime avec Jeanne c'est
que c'est une fille du peuple une fille
de la rue qui comprend que sa plus
grande arme dans la vie ce sera son
charme sa beauté
et que c'est le plus grand pouvoir de
l'humanité dans son tempérament il y a
des choses qui résonnaient en moi la
peur de
la sensation parfois
de trahir son origine de pas ne pas lui
rester fidèle de se sentir bien ni avec
les gens riches ni avec les gens pauvres
la peur de manquer la
tombée amoureuse d'un homme de pouvoir
qu'est-ce que ça
comment à l'époque c'était vu et
finalement c'est toujours ce regard là
accusateur dès qu'une femme tombe
amoureuse d'un homme de pouvoir elle
sera forcément
jugé critiquer à l'emporte-pièce l'amour
entre deux personnes que les classes
sociales opposent sont toujours jugés
de façon caricaturale sans effort sans
nuance
et j'ai eu la sensation
je crois pas en Dieu et tout je suis pas
du tout là-dedans mais j'ai eu la
sensation que j'étais choisie pour pour
parler d'elle pour parler de cet amour
là on voit l'image avec Johnny Depp je
peux pas faire l'impasse bien sûr sur
c'était quoi la complicité c'était quel
type de relation avec Johnny Depp en
fait c'est un animal de Johnny c'est
quelqu'un
qui déjà tous les matins il arrive avec
une humeur différente on peut jamais
savoir dans quelle humeur il va arriver
il y a parfois des humeurs où il est
très joyeux il a envie de d'essayer
plein de choses de rigoler avec les gens
et tout ça et il y a des moments où il
n'en a pas envie mais qui a toujours la
même Hummer il faut savoir quand même
que c'est quelqu'un qui est tout le
temps exposé qui sortait de deux procès
moi je peux comprendre moi quand je
reçois un recommandé déjà je suis nouée
toute la journée donc j'imagine que lui
il y avait des moments où on était très
complice évidemment c'est pas dans ces
moments là que les médias s'y
intéressent nos amis les médias
il a été dit que c'était l'enfer c'était
faux c'était pas du tout l'enfer il y a
eu des désaccords mais comme surtout les
tournages comme dans toutes les
entreprises comme partout ailleurs dès
lors que vous passez de moi ensemble
toute la journée avec des horaires qui
sont très lourds
c'est obligé qu'il y ait des désaccords
et puis je vous dis honnêtement je ne
lui en veux absolument pas parce que les
désaccords que nous avons eu sont la
preuve qu'il était énormément investi
qu'il voyait le roi d'une certaine
manière qu'il avait envie de défendre
des choses que que lui savait de Louis
XV et j'avais beau lui dire tu sais
johnny c'est pas un documentaire donc la
vérité lui il était basé sur les les
choses vraies de Louis XV
je remettais pas en cause mais je lui je
vais essayer de le ramener toujours à
l'idée que c'est un film de fiction et
que c'est c'était mon regard sur ce roi
là et aussi de
parler d'une histoire d'amour enfin et
après je disais oui le film c'est Jeanne
du Barry
donc moi je préfère mille fois
rencontrer des désaccords avec un acteur
parce qu'il est très investi que
rencontrer un acteur qui attend qui
castonne et qui ne me propose rien ce
qui vous a proposé Diego alors Diego
parce que parce qu'évidemment vous avez
dirigé Maïwenn votre propre fils il a 19
ans il est beau comme un dieu
il incarne Louis XVI qui doit initier
cette c'est il a pas du tout envie
d'être acteur il prend ça comme une
expérience comme un truc
sympa c'est vous qui l'avez sollicité
mais c'est moi qui l'ai sollicité alors
faut savoir que ça fait depuis 2016
depuis que j'écris le film que je
voulais lui donner le rôle de Louis XVI
parce que Louis XVI était quelqu'un dans
sa bulle
qui se sont étrangers à tout le bordel
de du luxe du confort du glamour
ça ça correspond au trait de caractère
de mon fils mon fils est pas du tout
matérialiste lui la seule chose qui
l'intéresse c'est le tennis c'est le
sport
et donc je trouvais que ça c'était celui
16 là que je voulais je voulais Diego
l'interprète parce que j'étais sûr qu'il
allait rendre un Louis XVI en plus
différent des Louis XV ce qu'on a
toujours vu au cinéma à savoir des Louis
XVI complètement
autiste sur leur serrure ce que Louis
XVI n'était pas à Louis XVI était
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus raffiné et
Rudy que les portraits qui ont été faits
au cinéma mais comment on le dirige son
propre fils sur un plateau où il côtoie
les autres acteurs comme les autres
comme les autres oui sauf que je suis
peut-être je disais chérie au début de
chaque phrase mais c'est tout est-ce que
vous voulez bien vous déplacer vers le
fauteuil gris vers Alger
alors je crois que la télécommande est
en toc bon écoutez
c'est pas très sympa alors voilà si vous
allez sur ce terrain là
non non
la magie opère oh oui ça y est ça a
opéré derrière aussi
[Musique]
regarde mise en scène par orasio mazaro
mais ici tous les personnages du
spectacle en s'inspirant de sa famille
elle raconte l'histoire d'une petite
fille programmée pour être star par une
mère abusive ah oui pardon je suis la
mère de Maïwenn
mes rêves passent pas par le désir des
autres mes rêves sont les choses que je
veux faire moi je crois que si ça plaît
c'est que les gens passent d'une émotion
à une autre c'est ce qu'on me dit
souvent
et oui on est en 2002 2003 sur votre
seul en scène le pois chiche joue au
café de la gare qui a fonctionné très
bien qui qui a fait que les gens se sont
déplacés en nombre alors pas toujours au
début d'ailleurs vous faisiez gagner des
places pour la petite anecdote et puis
ensuite sale comble elle est importante
cette étape dans votre vie vous en
parlez vraiment comme d'une seconde
naissance ça veut tout dire oui tout a
commencé grâce à ce spectacle c'était
c'était génial parce que en fait si je
vous dis que c'était génial c'est que je
me souviens très bien de ce qu'il y
avait dans ma tête à cette époque là je
me sentais libre je me sentais sans
prise de risque personne n'attendait au
tournant
personne ne venait vous voir le
spectacle en fait aucune aucun
journaliste donc il y a rien de mieux
pour créer que de savoir que personne va
venir nous voir alors une autre image si
vous voulez bien
bonjour
je voudrais acheter une caméra la voie
même la voix une caméra pour faire des
petits films de famille non pas du tout
non c'est pour faire un documentaire un
film pour le cinéma
pour le cinéma oui alors moi je peux
vous diriger vers une caméra
professionnelle mais c'est pas des
petits formats j'ai besoin que les gens
que je
voilà j'ai besoin que les gens que je
filme croient que c'est pas possible que
je fasse un film vous voyez ce que je
veux dire
là encore vous faites tout Maïwenn vous
écrivez vos produits vous jouez aussi
premier rôle oui c'était mon premier
film ouais c'est 2006 c'est je crois que
pardonnez-moi c'est plus un film sur un
fantasme plus que un film
autobiographique ce que je fais dans le
film je ne l'ai jamais fait
rien de ce que je fais dans le film
m'est arrivé mais j'ai toujours fantasmé
de le faire ce que vous êtes dans le
film permettez-moi de juste préciser
pour le téléspectateurs vous êtes
excessive capricieuse naïve
insupportable oui mais j'ai au moins le
mérite de me confronter
au personnage qui qui ont été violents
dans dans la vie de la trajectoire de
personnages voilà et c'est sûrement
quelque chose auquel j'ai jamais eu le
courage de m'affronter dans ce film d'en
pardonnez-moi vous insérez les rushs de
cette audition qui remonte à l'âge où
vous avez 7 ans oui absolument dans ce
moment là le directeur de casting vous
demande de la dernière fois où vous
aviez pleuré
il vous pose la question vous souvenez
ou pas
que c'était le moment de votre vie le
plus impudique j'ai jamais dit pourquoi
j'avais pleuré je me souviens très bien
de ce qui s'est passé dans ma tête c'est
qu'en vrai je savais très bien pourquoi
j'avais pleuré je crois que j'avais dû
encore pleurer pour la violence que je
subissais et que au moment où on pose la
question je sais que j'ai pas le droit
de dire la vérité donc j'ai dû inventer
un truc bénin que
je retombé par terre ou tomber dans les
escaliers je sais plus ce que j'ai dû
dire cette petite fille de 7 ans
qu'est-ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez quand vous êtes seul
avec vous-même
j'ai plus la nostalgie de ma période
avec mes enfants que la nostalgie de
quand j'étais enfant c'est vrai vous
êtes nostalgique de leur enfance oui
elle a 30 ans votre fille Shanna 19 ans
pour Diego quelle maman vous êtes enfin
ils sont grands maintenant c'est
compliqué de d'être une maman pour des
enfants qui sont grands si durs c'est
dur de savoir répondre ce qu'ils ont
envie de savoir se montrer présente sans
être oppressante étouffante
j'apprends tous les jours j'essaye des
nouvelles
des nouvelles astuces pour qu'ils
sentent que je suis toujours là mais je
crois que malheureusement ils ont plutôt
besoin de mon absence que de ma présence
mais quand je dis ça ils disent mais non
c'est pas vrai
la création elle est de plus en plus
féminine dans le cinéma Maïwenn vous
l'avez observé j'imagine rebeccas
bottovski Alice winocourt Sophie boudre
Mélissa drijard sophie Le Tourneur je
pourrais en citer d'autres
s'il y a une évolution vous la sentez
vous voyez ce qui s'opère le sexisme est
en baisse dans le dans l'industrie
cinématographique il y a toujours eu des
réalisatrices il y en a toujours eu
maintenant j'ai l'impression qu'on
parle plus des réalisatrices femmes en
rappelant que il y a des chiffres
enfin j'ai l'impression qu'on parle plus
de réalisatrices en les victimisant
quand les
quand les mettant en valeur quoi j'ai
enfin moi je préférais qu'on parle des
cinéastes en disant le film de Intel
mais sans stabiloter que c'est une femme
la meilleure façon d'être féministe
c'est de faire exactement comme les
hommes c'est-à-dire
d'exister avec son art son travail sans
se victimiser sans
revendiquer son sexe on revendique un
cerveau votre féminisme à vous si je dis
féministe dans le fond féminine dans la
forme est-ce que c'est proche de votre
philosophie bien sûr je le suis
dans la forme et dans le fond mais pas
de façon radicale je suis féministe en
aimant les hommes et les hommes sont
très féministes la plupart des hommes
que je fréquente
je vois pas le potentiel agresseur dans
leur regard ou alors c'est pas possible
vous vous sentez rejoint ou pas
totalement dans votre voix dans ce
discours là mais oui oui tous les gens
autour de moi sont désolés que ce monde
soit restitué avec peu de nuances mais
c'est comme si les nuances étaient plus
n'était plus audible
et puis il y a le problème des médias
aussi les médias adorent les discours
radicaux
c'est beaucoup plus
vendeur Vendeur il y a beaucoup plus de
clics de buzz tous ces mots là que je
déteste alors une image si vous voulez
bien
tu cherches quoi justement qu'est-ce que
tu veux vivre sans toi ne plus te voir
tu vas pouvoir faire ce que tu veux
quand tu veux personne fera de créer
moi je fais le chercher tu as bien vu
que j'étais un mec avec des potes avec
des bouteilles tu m'as vu tu m'as
calculé quand même tu es une avocate
c'est pas comme je t'avais trouvé un mec
dans une bibliothèque
on quitte les gens pour la même raison
exactement laquelle je pense tirer en
premier
donc ça veut dire que le prochain va
t'attirer pour une raison et tu vas le
quitter encore une fois tu sais il y a
un moment il faut construire hein
2015 mon roi j'adore cette scène ouais
on adore cette scène ce film avec
Emmanuel Berco Vincent Cassel
bouleversant troublant de justesse j'ai
dû le voir 5 ou 6 fois j'ai arrêté de
compter sans doute que ça fait écho
aussi à une part de vie une part
d'improvisation aussi est-ce que dans
cette scène c'est le cas oui franchement
ce film n'aurait pas été ce qu'il est
sans le génie de Cassel
c'était exceptionnel il était tellement
fort que un moment donné il a c'est
comme s'il avait renversé le scénario
comme si on pouvait ne plus comprendre
le personnage féminin mais sur le
tournage on parlait beaucoup des
rapports homme-femme et c'était marrant
parce que même le moindre régisseur
stagiaire donnait sa perception des
choses entre hommes femmes donc c'était
un espèce de c'était une espèce
d'écriture
collégiale pendant tout le tournage avec
quand même une vocation thérapeutique
ça aussi c'est
non c'est impossible de se laver ou de
se soigner par les films peut-être qu'il
y a des gens qui tiennent à notre
discours par rapport à ça en tout cas
moi en l'occurrence ce qui m'a sauvé de
mes
séquelles de mon enfance se sont
absolument pas d'avoir fait des films ce
sont l'analyse prendre soin de soi
et ce qui m'a aidé c'est que le cinéma
m'a donné beaucoup d'amour beaucoup de
reconnaissance mais c'est pas les sujets
de mes films qui m'ont soigné mais
aujourd'hui vous êtes comment maintenant
je
je j'estime que je n'ai plus l'âge d'en
vouloir à mes parents mais je n'ai plus
là de me faire insulter non plus voilà
donc c'est la limite que je donne entre
eux et moi ils ont le droit de pas être
fier de moi ils ont le droit de me
critiquer tout ça tout ce qu'ils veulent
mais je veux pas qu'il m'insulte
bye voulait bien
vous déplacer oui
alors cet appartement évidemment il a
été pensé pour vous en tout cas
accessoiriser pour vous alors encore un
petit peu plus loin si vous voulez faire
quelque part vers la cheminée en la
dépassant ça c'est le premier film que
j'ai vu quand j'étais petite et
alors ma mère m'avait emmené et il faut
savoir que l'histoire de ce film c'est
l'histoire d'une mère qui veut tout
faire pour que sa fille devienne une
star tout est dit voilà et donc j'étais
dans la salle et du coup comme ce que je
voyais correspondait à ma vie de
l'époque j'étais persuadée que c'était
le film de ma mère et donc
j'ai mis du temps à comprendre que
c'était juste un très grand cinéaste
qu'il avait fait
dans mon inconscient de gamine j'ai
l'impression que ma vie dans un film
existait déjà un peu comme une mise en
abyme je sais que vous aimez ça
typiquement ça doit être déconcertant
alors est-ce que vous voulez écouter un
disque et plutôt nous proposer de
découvrir un de vos disques il y en a
d'autres de chadets où il y a que
celui-là alors là on a fait une petite
sélection forcément oui donc il y a que
celui-là mais vous pouvez vous asseoir
et choisir entre chadets
à mi-moine house Madonna alors je suis
j'ai pas de vinyle chez moi j'ai vu que
tous les gens qui étaient dans
l'émission ils savaient très bien manier
les vinyles
il y a disons que il y a des petits
coups de main
alors écoutez là vous vous tentez en
tout cas l'expérience
j'aime tellement zapper comme ça alors
ok
si on me disait qui tu veux ressembler
si on peut faire un coup de baguette
magique je dirais Chade
[Musique]
la femme la plus
sensuelle de la planète
[Musique]
mais la musique mais parfois mais me
trop alors
il y a des moments je me sens forte pour
un écouter et puis
[Musique]
voilà
Maïwenn on a
un cadeau pour vous ah oui
dans l'angle du canapé à côté des fleurs
[Musique]
alors par devant comme un petit aimant
et voilà
trop gentil attends c'est quoi
soyez les bienvenus voyage de la
Méditerranée au Sahara aux éditions La
Martinière vous pouviez pas me faire
plus plaisir vous l'avez pas donc non un
formidable quasiment tout sur l'Algérie
moi je suis dépensière alors voilà il
aura j'espère une jolie place dans votre
bibliothèque
c'est le c'est le récit des auteurs qui
ont passé quatre mois en Algérie avec
les dessins aussi qui vont bien les
photos les images
on a presque les odeurs en fait en
parcourant ce livre vous verrez maïwan
c'est trop bien
Maïwenn on a envie d'avoir une photo de
vous est-ce que vous voulez bien vous
pliez à l'exercice ce petit rituel de
fin d'émission
donc m'avait dit quoi l'appareil photo
il se trouve dans la bibliothèque de
gauche
vous pouvez le laisser sur l'étagère il
suffit juste d'appuyer sur la petite
étiquette orange qui est face à vous et
de prendre la télécommande en main hop
ça va s'allumer
ça y est et ben voilà il y a plus qu'à
parfait je la laisse là oui s'il vous
plaît
merci Maïwenn je vais venir vous saluer
merci Maïwenn merci à tous d'être venu
nous voir ça s'appelle Jeanne Dubarry
bien sûr à Cannes sur la Croisette on
vous attend on sera à vos côtés merci là
je sais que on est enregistré donc je
fais attention à ce que je dis
je connais les pièges
c'est sympa j'aimerais bien que ça vive
pareil
[Musique]